in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio today is dr. bound clinician he's
an expert in longevity and president of
the German society of anti-aging
medicine welcome to this studio hello
hello and what happens in our body as we
age well it's different factors that are
responsible one for example its
oxidation the effect of free radicals
hormone or lack of hormones is another
factor quite a new reason to theory of
aging is silent inflammations or chronic
low level informations that I in our
body and that are really the cause of
different age related with disease like
arteriosclerosis also dimensi are and
even cancer if we do have rotten teeth
that means that we age earlier you know
it's rotten teeth but also another
source of those silent information is
fatty tissue especially that in the
abdomen so that is also one of the
reasons why obese people do have
shortened life expectancy ok so we can
really do something about it so it's not
just all in our genes hold it will be
better true so it's something like
thirty percent that is in our genes but
it's seventy percent lifestyle so
there's actually a lot about that what
we can do about aging and the process of
aging is not just written in our genes
but it's something that we can influence
so every family has this story about
some some distant uncle who smoked and
drank and never did any sports and still
longer get until the age of 100 so so is
there any choose to this kind of stories
some of them are true but
modern medicine does not really rely on
anecdotes but it relies on statistics
and it relies on good studies and the
statistics and the studies they tell us
a very clear message and that is smoking
is reducing your life expectancy doing
exercise eating world is prolonging it
okay so and if I personally want to have
a good head start and I want to do
something against this aging when when
should I start how early should i start
our best is to start in the uterus we
know that the way that your mother
behaves what she eats which it does
during pregnancy is really determining
your fade later in life but okay you
have little influence on that otherwise
yes prevention should start as early as
possible but on the other hand it's
never too late to do the right things so
it's never too late to do anything for
this yeah okay and what about exercise
we saw this in in the film and is there
any single exercise you would recommend
for anti-aging purposes actually I would
even suggest that you mix it a little
bit there's two main directions in
exercise one is more directed to
endurance and one is more directed to
muscle building and for a long time we
concentrate it very much on endurance
and now we know that muscles are
important for example in the prevention
of osteoporosis you need the action of
muscles to build up bone density and
even to keep your body weight muscles
are burning calories 24 hours a day so
the more muscles you have the better you
keep your body weight dr. clinical do I
need vitamin supplements or is good
healthy food enough well for a long time
vitamins were big topic in anti-aging
medicine and by taking for example high
dose of vitamin C or vitamin E we
believed by down-regulating oxidative
stress we could prolong life to let our
lifespan the recent studies were a
little bit disappointing according to
this but on the other hand does not mean
that we do not need supplements for
example in Germany we have a very long
winter and then we got get into white I
mean D deficiency and then it's of
course a very good thing to take vitamin
D and there is a micronutrient
as well that we need like folic acid and
so on until we need to see my GP my
doctor just to get me myself checked on
vitamin D deficiency or is it okay when
I say okay I live in a long winter
country so I'd better take it well you
can measure vitamin D levels and
whatever you can measure then it's good
to do so but if you do not have the
possibility then in wintertime you can
just take it like that as well what
about the methods and trick of
anti-aging medicine seems to be caloric
restriction meaning rock muddy
overeating essentially so is there any
truth about this yes there is in fact we
have very good studies with many with
animals and they show for example that
rats in the laboratory when they are fed
thirty percent less nutrition then they
will live up to fifty percent more and
this has been shown in other species as
well so calorie restriction yes it does
work but on the other hand it's
difficult to applied to human beings
because let's just don't get more food
and we still have the chance to call the
pizza service or something else and in
time where most of the people have big
difficulties just to keep their body
weight on a normal level then calorie
restriction is not really an option for
the majority of the people but one trick
might be just to cancel the dinner the
so-called dinner canceling dinner
calientes network dinner cancelling is a
special way of calorie restriction of
course if you quit one meal then it's
also dinner canceling the other thing is
that when you cancel your dinner then
you get in a sort of a hypoglycemia
during the night and this is also a
stimulus for your brain to secrete more
growth hormone and that is an extra
effect of dinner cancelling and if I
don't want to cut away all my food M is
there any other way to mimic this effect
like this fair trial for instance yes
restaurants role is a so-called CR
mimetic so a substance that mimics the
effects of calorie restriction that's
the good news the bad news is from what
you get in red wine you should have to
drink something like 12 or 15 bottles a
day to get the right amount of rest
retro and that
something that's not really good for
your liver so we have to wait for auto
supplements or maybe for a
pharmacologically improved resveratrol
which has the same effect okay and
anti-aging medicine is not all about
longevity it's also rod looking healthy
and looking young isn't itself so what
benefit the benefit do you get from you
can't looking young yeah that's a
aesthetic anti-aging and it's a part of
the package so it's not what we are
mainly dealing with but of course you
cannot exclude it and in fact looking
younger often helps to feel younger and
that as I said is part of the package
but anti-aging medicine as we see it is
more a preventive medicine against
age-related disease so it's really more
than just skin deep great thank you for
the insights dr. cranum lot to learn to
stay healthy pleasure TV thank you again